and we all thought it was the best idea
we'd ever heard that was genius who knew
vampires were such good dancers the epic
conclusion to the twilight saga had
plenty of memorable moments that fans
loved the behind the scenes of this film
was chock full with even more moments
that will give you a whole new
perspective on your favorite characters
it's good to get physical when i've
always literally stood behind people and
been like from the hard work put in to
create your favorite moments to bloopers
and pranks between the cast and crew
these are the behind the scenes moments
that will make you love twilight even
more
she's amazing right
[Music]
during the final battle with the voltori
rennes may is sitting on jacob's wolf
form while the wolves have been
completely computer generated throughout
the series in this case actress
mackenzie foy is sitting on an
animatronic rig that was designed to
look like the midsection of the wolf
they actually used two different
versions of the rake for filming one
version was operated manually by a crew
member just off screen with the motion
being used to assist the final animation
we see the other rig was motion
controlled which they programmed to move
according to animation they had already
done that was new for us that was pretty
fun
i was born to be a vampire
director bill condon knew that bella
needed to have a unique vampire look
that differentiated her from her mortal
look a big part of the new look had to
do with bella's costume and how she was
much more confident and powerful now her
new look included leather a black color
scheme and more form-fitting clothing it
also included colored contact lenses so
irritate your eyes at first
which stuart hated this is one thing i
can't wait to say goodbye to even though
it wasn't the most comfortable
experience for stewart we think her
vampire look is awesome and showed off a
whole new badass side to her character
bella
she's got your eyes bella if you thought
the cgi baby was creepy wait till you
see what they originally used
they had an animatronic doll that was
puppeteered off camera and it looked
creepy so creepy that it was nicknamed
chuck esme after the evil killer doll
wick godfrey the creator of the doll
hated it as well is one of the most
grotesque animatronic babies you know
ever to not be seen on film knowing this
we're glad they went with the weird cgi
baby instead
he would just turn into this completely
different person after deciding the
animatronic baby was nightmare fuel they
brought in real babies to fill the part
robert pattinson absolutely adored all
the babies they had on set he would just
turn into this completely different
person whenever they would take a baby
away from him he would complain and
argue why they have to keep taking them
pattinson had a great time acting with
the babies and children and it shows in
his performance
telling war stories
or just standing there like freaking
statues
the epic final battle scene showcases
the wolf pack attacking the voltori in
an awesome badass sequence the behind
the scenes however not as epic since the
wolves were completely animated the
animators needed reference to work with
so on set they had crew members hold
giant cardboard cutouts of wolves
feigning the action of the battle they
called the cardboard cutouts the wolf
standees and used them for multiple
moments during the battle this includes
the cardboard wolves pretending to
attack the volturi and the epic shot of
all the wolves running towards the fight
which looks a bit more silly with their
cardboard stand-ins it's hard to watch
the scene the same way after seeing this
the main thing is not to move too fast
turning into a vampire comes with a lot
of new abilities most of which require
stunt work stuart loved to do her own
stunts and would get upset whenever she
couldn't she's like pissed off when a
double has to do anything that being
said some of the stunt work was a little
too much for her she was clearly filled
with nervous excitement while doing some
of her stunts laughing after each take
jesus christ i don't know why i can't
handle that i can't handle it
[Music]
pattinson also did a lot of his own
stunt work including some pretty intense
wire work that was pretty fun however he
had trouble doing one stunt in
particular a simple somersault he failed
on multiple takes while his co-star
kristen stewart nailed it every time
pattinson had the whole crew laughing at
his inability to complete a simple stunt
he went to his stunt double for help who
can be seen putting his head in his
hands after a failed attempt by
pattinson
very proud to have her be playing my
daughter mackenzie foy was one of the
last additions to the main cast coming
on to play rena's may all the other cast
members made her feel welcome and would
play games with her on set she played
football with taylor a game where
someone tries to catch her hands and
would have staring contests with
everyone the cast only had nice things
to say about her praising her for her
hard work mackenzie's great she's very
self-possessed for a very really young
girl
come time for reshoots robert pattinson
was ready in all aspects except one his
hair he had cut it before reshoots began
meaning it wasn't the right style for
edward he ended up wearing a wig which
he hated he branded it frankenstein's
monster we still think he looks great
the final battle begins with the cullens
and wolves running at the voltori they
filmed this scene on a large soundstage
with a green screen backdrop the actors
actually ran at full speed while the
cameras followed them they had to film
this scene multiple times which meant
running running and more running we can
only imagine how tired the actors were
after recording this scene
what makes the final battle scene so
shocking is that it isn't in the book
the original ending in the book was
deemed too boring so stephanie meyer and
writer melissa rosenberg came up with
the idea of the giant ending battle the
way i approached it was who would be the
most shocking to kill and because
they're all there for carlisle it made
sense he was the one rosenberg was at
the premiere of the movie and watched as
the audience screamed and yelled during
the scene director bill condon addressed
the risk it was taking the worst thing
would be if people felt pissed off we
would say the risk paid off
you're in it you just gotta join in
during filming for the final battle all
the actors who were on the cullen side
orchestrated a dance-off prank they
choreographed an entire dance and got
the audio and camera crews in on it as
well when action was called the audio
crew played a song and the colons all
lined up to perform their dance moves
the voltori actors and director bill
condon had no idea what was going on
this prank was actually included as a
post-credit surprise when the film was
released in theaters
you know whatever they'll let me do i'll
do ashley greene who played alice was
more than up to the task of doing her
own stunts she has a martial arts
background and was routinely practicing
for her stunt work if i know there's a
stun sequence i'm you know in the gym
training by myself to make sure i'm kind
of up to the task and working with stun
trainer she performed some wire work
including doing a stunt in a harness she
could twist in the final shot looks
amazing and shows that green's hard work
paid off
vampires have superhuman strength and
regularly show it off the behind the
scenes however makes their strength a
little less impressive emmett actor
kellen lutz can be seen carrying a giant
prop rock placing it down without any
effort this prop was a breakaway which
stuart and lutz can be seen breaking
with ease it's not the first time lutz
has handled such props in a
behind-the-scenes photo from breaking
dawn part 1 he and his co-star nikki
reed can be seen casually carrying giant
tree props
stewart's last day on set was anything
but glamorous while running barefoot
through a fake forest stewart stepped on
something not too pleasant the very last
thing i did was step on a rusty nail
ouch that's a rough last day but stewart
took it in stride claiming it was
exactly what she wanted it was literally
perfect we wouldn't expect anything less
from the twilight veteran at this point
we're not sure what we love more the
epic final battle between our heroes and
the voltori or all the behind the scene
shenanigans that took place while
filming it the epic conclusion to the
twilight saga was under a lot of
pressure to deliver a satisfying finale
which we think it did a great job in
doing director bill condon worked well
with his actors and was passionate about
making this film special it's nice to
know that everyone got along and had fun
while creating this film and it helps us
appreciate it even more what was your
favorite behind the scenes moment